the first main speaker at this year's
world economic forum meeting was not in
davos
president zielenski continues to direct
military efforts in kiev and has not
left his country since the russian
invasion he appealed for more funding
for the defense of his country and to
pay for its reconstruction
ukraine needs funding at least 5 billion
us dollars per month this is why we
establish a fund for rebuilding ukraine
called united 24 we call upon everyone
to join this
president zielenski called for russian
assets in the west to be seized and
given to ukraine the head of a leading
think tank told me it's a proposal
that's now likely to be discussed in
capitals
an interesting debate that will emerge
soon
is whether the europeans and north
americans will move
from freezing russian state assets to
seizing those state assets and using
putin's war
chest as ukraine's reparations fund and
that is a debate that we haven't yet had
in the international economic community
because of covid this year's davos isn't
happening in the snow in january it was
cancelled last year and postponed
earlier this year normally russian
officials attend but this year the
building used for the russia house
exhibition center has been transformed
to highlight human rights abuses it's
been renamed the house of russian war
crimes
the war in ukraine will continue to
reverberate around davos as meetings
continue here this week not just the
events on the ground but the economic
effects with a simultaneous global
energy crisis and global food crisis
james bay's al jazeera davos